well let's get the thoughts of labour
now i'm joined here in the studio by the
shadow justice secretary steve reed good
to see you this morning thank you thanks
for coming to see us on sky news where
does labour stand on more restrictions
given the situation that we are in today
or more restrictions to do with omicron
well
the key to avoiding those and we all
want to avoid them if if it's possible
is to make sure that testing gets out
and works properly now we've got a
problem at the moment because the
government was relying on testing to
keep us safe during this period but they
haven't ensured that there is a
sufficient supply of tests available for
people to make sure before they go out
that they haven't got covenant one of
the reasons we're seeing this big
increase in infections is if people
can't check before they go out they may
be infected they go out and they infect
other people that is what leads to the
risk of a higher level of lockdown we
don't want to see that the government
needs to get a grip on testing
immediately
but testing doesn't fix the situation
that we've got currently with staff
shortages acute staff shortages in
hospitals particularly in london where
we've got armed forces personnel
that's right i mean the government lost
control by failing to make sure the
tests were
were available and we do need to now be
prioritizing what tests are available
for those key workers essential services
the national health services and making
sure we keep the schools open because
kids school kids in particular have lost
too much education already so we're
having to cope with the situation that
results from government failure to make
sure that failure doesn't doesn't morph
into further restrictions and even
another lockdown they need to get an
urgent grip on testing and roll that out
i'm hearing that from you loud and clear
about the testing what i'm not hearing
from you is whether labour would be
advocating more restrictions we're not
no what we would advocate is
prioritizing the emergency services and
key workers for the tests that are
available and for keeping the schools
open we have to prioritize because the
government's left us with too few tests
okay so you would almost be alongside
the government in that they seem to be
in a place where they want us to be
living with the virus is that labor you
have to rely on the science you know if
the scientists say that the virus is
sufficiently um uh spreading at such a
rate and causing a risk of overwhelming
the nhs then we have to listen to the
scientists but no one wants to go there
we don't want more lockdowns the
government has put us in the position
where we're even having to consider them
now so let's get those tests on stream
let's prioritize essential workers so we
can avoid another lockdown on all the
damage that does to people's family life
mental health and the economy okay and
despite the calls coming from senior
people within the nhs who are saying you
know help the nhs is very close to being
overwhelmed you would still
not bring in
we will prioritize the nhs if we were um
in government and to be honest if we
were in government and we were going to
rely on testing we would have made sure
there were tests available that i'm
afraid uh is is another example of this
government's sheer and utter
incompetence they've put us in this
position we must protect the nhs and
education that's where we'll prioritize
the tests to avoid a lockdown another
looming crisis is of course the cost of
living one which is going to come to
bite isn't it very very soon what is
labour's proposal for addressing that
well i mean the situation you've got is
absolutely we've got is absolutely
terrifying at the moment we've got the
highest rate of inflation for nearly 30
years this spring will have the highest
rates of personal taxation for for 70
years and we've we're just going through
uh the worst decade for wage growth
since the great depression of the 1930s
and on top of all of that now people are
seeing their fuel bills heating bills
for their homes going up potentially for
two thousand pounds a year labor is
calling on the government to immediately
scrap v80 or on on on energy bills and
fuel bills to get us through that much
of a dent in it though doesn't it
it's 20 off your fuel bill now i i think
that will that will help people in the
short term what we're saying is let's
get that helps richer people doesn't it
because they spend a higher proportion
of their money we're talking about a
short-term um solution here not v80 off
this went winstree if you look at some
of the alternatives like increasing the
warm homes discount which certainly
should be increased the government's
frozen it for seven years now that would
take weeks and weeks to put in place and
we might not be it might not be until
the spring until it made any difference
to people by that point they've already
lost all of the money on their heating
bills so a v80 cut now can be
implemented immediately and help
households are feeling really feeling
the squeeze on their bills right now so
let's do that longer term we need to
look at how we manage this system
differently and one of the big things
we'd be looking at doing there is
insulating homes the government's scraps
of grant funding to allow people to
insulate their homes and make them more
energy efficient as a result of that we
have the least energy efficient homes in
europe and because of that this crisis
in energy costs is hitting british
families harder than than across the
artist we're nearly out of time we
haven't even got on to the moj stuff
that i know that you wanted to talk
about but i do want to ask you quickly
about the text messages that have come
to light from the prime minister to lord
brownlow um asking for more money for
his flat and saying ps um re the great
exhibition two a project of lord
brownlow i'm on it what is labour's
perception of how that looks
is it cash for accidents it stinks it
does it does appear to be cash for
access it appears that lord brownlow had
access to the prime minister because he
was paying to refurbish his fat flat for
the to the tune of a hundred thousand
pounds that of itself is corruption but
the second point you raised there this
great exhibition to the that was the
quid pro quo it looked like he was
helping the prime minister in order to
get the prime minister to funnel
taxpayers money to support this great
exhibition too what's the difference
between the great exhibition two that
lord brownlow was asking for and
festival uk that the government is
running this summer
you would call for more investigation on
that and just final word from you you
also have questions about spending in
the mlj the moj has wasted 230
million pounds this year that would be
enough to pay for 5 000 police officers
and on this show before you've talked
about the fact that reported rapes only
0.6 percent of them ever ended a
prosecution if the government wasn't so
incompetently wasting tens of millions
of pounds we could have those extra
police officers and then people who are
reporting rape could have some sense
that they have a chance of getting
justice all right steve reed thank you
for coming to see us this morning it's
my pleasure